he actually changed my mind uh quite a
bit on the subject
do you think it could be a threat now
you don't no on free will
because i never
like before i met lex like yesterday
before that i thought that free will was
just an
illusion and everything is a result
of causality right right determine
terminology determinism
that's right a lot of people don't know
what that's called determinism
but lex came up with a
like very good argument and now i i'm
not so sure anymore
i think both things are true i think
it's like many things involving human
beings
there's not an absolute in one side or
the other for sure
free will is the thing because we both
know
about discipline we both know how
difficult it is like you know more than
anybody how difficult it is when you're
in
like a full training camp and you're
exhausted but you know you have the work
that you have to do and there's some
people that will find a way out of that
work
they'll they'll quit or they'll they'll
not answer their phone
or they'll take time off and then
there's other people that will just bite
down
and deal with it and be uncomfortable
but do the work
that's free will that's that's
discipline there's something but
why can you do it and why can other
people not do it
like what about how much of your
personality
was instilled upon you because of your
genetics
because of your life experiences because
of the environment that you
you grew up in how much of it was the
people that you experienced when you
were younger
that showed you the value and the
benefit of hard work
and how many of the people that you
mirrored were lazy
and and then found excuses and maybe you
maybe you lean towards them like
how much of determinism is true how much
of free will is true
it's a balance there's there's a lot of
both things
that's that's right i you know in a
mechanical world
if a car broke we're not going to say
this
the car decide to break right or
if the trees fall down we're not going
to say the trees decide to break maybe
the asymmetry of the tree
makes it falls down maybe there's a
reason why but i feel
that us as human beings sometimes or ego
want us to be in control of the universe
which is i do not believe it's the case
so that's why i
tend to before i met lex i was a hundred
percent
convinced there is no free will and uh
you know ev everything is decide
determined by
causality now i'm not so sure because
about with that we
talk about consciousness what it is and
he had some incredible argument and
he made me see a different point of view
that i never never seen before
well just think about this think about
how many people seek out inspiration
think about how valuable it is like matt
frazier was on my podcast a couple of
weeks ago he was a
five-time crossfit champion and uh one
of the things that he does now he has
this art collection
that he's selling on his website and all
it's all these
inspirational quotes and the idea is to
put up this art with all these
inspirational quotes
and that will give you fuel to get
through your workouts or get through
difficult things you want to do in your
life
we all are like how many people post
inspirational things online
and then how many people like you know
read those things and get excited and it
inspires them to action
there's some real cause and effect
that's right
where there's inspiration and then
there's action that's motivated by that
inspiration whether it's
going to the rock's instagram and
watching at five o'clock in the morning
the rock here working out
in the the the church of iron you know
like all the [ __ ] that that guy does or
all these other
cam haines or david goggins all these
other inspirational people that are
online why are they so
motivational why do so many people flock
to them because there's
there's a reality to the there's a give
and take to these things and there's
certain things that inspire you to
action you can externally be motivated
by those things it's not necessarily
a 100 determinism there's there is some
free will
well however there's for example
a quote that can inspire you but to me
it doesn't have the same effect because
of my background it doesn't
get me to my core because i cannot rely
really much to it
so it's a little bit of determinism
because it's the causality that makes it
who i
am and who you are that makes it the the
effect of
that coat as on your is different than
it has on me
or you could both grow up in the same
environment you could have a brother
that's inspired by things that are not
even remotely inspirational to you
but to him it's everything whether it's
music
or whether it's a movie or a book or
whatever it is
it's true like in in families very often
you have
someone who's going the right way and
maybe perhaps one of
his siblings will go the wrong way yeah
and we always
tend to say oh we don't understand
because they've been raised the same way
but they did not
yeah the moment you you take one of your
kid in your arm and the other one is
looking at
at the kid that you're you know it's it
changed everything you know what i mean
yeah it's very hard to understand but
but i i'm not saying that
i'm convinced that there is no free will
but i
i don't know now he didn't completely
convince me he didn't complete me
make me change my mind but he he's got
his point in
and now man i i don't know i think the
real
problem is people that are convinced one
way or the other that's the real problem
because it is an open-ended
on uh conversation i don't think they're
really
i think determinism is a real factor but
i also think
will is a real factor too in that
there's something about
the open-ended variability of your
decisions
and what you decide to do what you don't
decide to do and there's moments in your
life we go
[ __ ] i'm going to do it i'm going to
go for it and when you do go for it your
life changes like what
makes you say [ __ ] it i'm gonna go for
it it depends entirely on
what happened that day to you it depends
entirely on how you feel whether or not
you got rest
whether or not you you broke up with a
girlfriend or she broke up with you or
you got fired from a job or you quit a
job
or you took on a new path in life like
all those different things play a factor
but there's also your own personal
decision making that's based on
your own personality and maybe your own
life experiences there's so many things
involved but for sure we all value
discipline we all value the ability to
take action well why do we do that
because we know it's a variable it comes
and goes it ebbs and flows
and sometimes it's there and sometimes
it's not it's like what is that
expression there's a there's an old
expression i don't remember who said it
but
that inspiration is like bathing it's
effective but you need to do it daily
[Music]
and i think there's something to that
it's like you need to seek out
inspiration
and that's why again people like david
goggins are so
inspirational because you can go to his
page every day and that motherfucker's
running 30 miles a day
you know i mean like there's something
to that like you get you get
you get fuel out of that there's people
like my friend cam haynes there's people
or the rock or whoever it is
they give you fuel you see them training
hard you go oh there's fuel in that yeah
like
i want to go train they are unbreakable
you have an unbreakable will
and this is very uh inspirational yeah
that's right
so there's two things happening there's
one it's like
yeah you are a lot of who you are
because of genetics and because of life
experience
because of all the things that have
happened to you but there's also
decisions that you make there's lines in
the sandwich you draw
there's moments where you say i am going
to do something different now
i'm tired of this [ __ ] like people that
are drunk their whole life and [ __ ] up
on drugs and then one day they go
enough enough i don't want to do this
anymore i'm going to change
and they have inspiration and then they
go to a 12-step program and
they meet other people that also have
inspiration and they feed off of each
other
i think it's important to face adversity
at it helps if you face it at a very
young age because it's
it molds you yeah especially if you
able to overcome it because if you've
never faced adversity
before and when you face it for the
first time and you're not prepared for
it
it can break you yes it can make you
fold
right you see that very often in in the
career of them in mixed martial art
guided
some of the guys they've been protected
for too long and then when they face a
real challenge they fall
yes same thing in anything and i think
guys perhaps like david goggins
or you know when i heard their back
stories because they faced adversity
they had to face an incredible amount of
adversity and they
were able to overcome each of it
and they become stronger because what
doesn't kill you make you stronger right
or it [ __ ] you up to the point where
you're weaker than you were before
exactly but i think it's it's a little
bit life i think it could be like a
fight
if you gradually face adversity yes
it's like someone who's you know someone
who's very let's say someone who's very
healthy
always pay everything for his kids you
know his kids is not used to learn the
the the importance of hard work you know
what i mean i think it's very important
like to to teach that to to kids you
know like the importance of hard work
the importance of adversity
the importance of you know not to break
them right
when they're young and make them lost
lose their confidence because i believe
confidence is everything right if you
don't have
you can have all the skills in the in
the world but if you don't have
confidence it's like someone who has a
lot of money in his bank account
but no way of accessing it right so by
facing adversity
and overcome it you're building your
confidence that's why sports are so
important yeah man
and life and same thing in business you
you're gonna reach
time that you you're gonna go down and
sometimes you might
you might go to the down deep
but if you face adversity before you're
used to overcome
those those obstacles you'll bounce back
from it yes
that's why like like i know a lot of
people sometimes they they
they face adversity and they fall they
can't stand up from it
and some people like let's help them
let's help them but if you help
them you always give them help they will
rely on that they need to learn from
themselves and sometimes i think there
is nothing better than
reach the down deep to find out
like how strong you are to come back
from
from that you know yeah well that's a
lot of things that people say when
they're talking about
experiencing drug addiction or
alcoholism they have to hit rock bottom
they hit rock bottom and then they
realize they don't want to be there
anymore and then they build themselves
back up they
experience that adversity and they
overcome it that doesn't break them